Our need to belong is one of the strongest of the human needs. However,
unfortunately, there are times when we're rejected. Rejection can lead to a
variety of negative consequences, including loneliness, isolation, and even
pain.
[NOISE]
Now this is a perfect time to bring up bullying, and the negative consequences
of bullying. When a person's bullied, he or she is rejected and often ridiculed
by others. Rejection can be overwhelming and actually cause pain for the
person. Do you remember in the sensation and perception lesson when we talked
about social pain activating the exact same part of the brain as physical pain?
So when people say being rejected hurts, it really is painful. Some of the
other problems associated with rejection are eating disorders, more health
problems, depression, and, tragically, sometimes suicide.